here's a common mistake that I see in
Python this code computes the sum of all
the unique numbers in a list
we Loop through the numbers and check if
we've seen the current number if not we
append it to our scene list and add the
number to our sum
in this version we use a list but with
very slight modifications we could have
used a set dictionary or Tuple instead
yes I know for this specific problem you
could also use this slick one-liner but
the problem here is just a stand-in for
this General pattern of doing a loop and
repeatedly checking if you've seen
something each iteration
so how much of a difference does
changing the data structure make let's
give it a try on a thousand ten thousand
and a hundred thousand numbers
on a thousand elements clearly Tuple and
lists are doing much worse than set in
dict but this is python does a few
milliseconds matter
ten thousand is a bit more of an
annoyance though set and dict are still
sitting around a millisecond but Tuple
and list are now approaching a full
second of runtime
wow and keep in mind this is just for
one function call not your whole program
if you need to call this function a
hundred times you're now waiting minutes
if you use Tuple or list but still a
fraction of a second for set and dict
for a hundred thousand numbers set
indict are using 10 to 20 milliseconds
but tupeland lists are now taking
minutes to complete
that performance is bad enough that even
if you don't care about performance you
probably care when it's that bad
and that's because of course performance
is relative
if you're writing a high-speed trading
system a microsecond might be an
eternity
if you're painting frames to the screen
maybe you only care if your computation
exceeds 16 milliseconds to reach your
60fps goal
if you're scriping data from your
favorite websites as long as it takes
under a minute you might not mind
waiting
or if you're Computing something that
only needs to be computed once you may
well be perfectly happy waiting hours or
days for a computation to complete
rather than spending weeks or months
devising a clever way to compute it
faster
the difference here is in the Big O run
times of the in operator and adding an
element
for less than Tuple using involves
looping over all the elements until you
either find what you're looking for or
if you check all of them whereas for set
and dict in takes advantage of the hash
table based implementation in order to
calculate where the item would go if it
was present and only check that location
in other words in is a linear or Big O
of n operation for less than Tuple but a
constant time or Big O of 1 operation
for said indict in the case of the Tuple
appending one element is also a linear
operation since tuples are immutable and
you have to copy all the old elements
into a new Tuple that's one larger
however for list dict and set adding one
element is what's called amortized
constant time which is a fancy way of
saying that adding a single element
might do a lot of work but if you add n
elements then the total amount of work
is still just o of n this often happens
in geometrically growing data structures
like list set and dict that have some
capacity and when you exceed that
capacity you have to go get more memory
and copy everything over to a new
location but if you have spare capacity
then you can just immediately put a new
element in one of your unused spots
assuming that the runtime of adding the
numbers is negligible this makes the set
and dict versions of N and the list and
Tuple versions o of N squared which is
what we call In The Biz in accidentally
quadratic algorithm
now Big O is in everything especially on
small inputs but in this case it's the
reason for making this code unbearably
slow so make sure that you know your Big
O time and space complexities for all
the basic operations on common types
because yeah even in Python performance
matters sort of